تواجهم اوروبي لتصنيف الحركه الدوريه
منظمه ارهابيه وماكرون قلق من افتقار
طهران لشفافيه في برنامجها النووي
شرطه يستبعد وانت تحول الحرب في اوكرانيا
الى صراع بين موسكو والنيتو وقصف الروسيه
على 50
والمعارضه التركيه تعلن برنامجها
الانتخابيه اليوم لهزيمه اردوغان وتخطط
لاعاده النظام البرلماني بدلا من الرئاسي
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم مشاهدينا بكل الخير
واهلا بكم الى فتره اخباريه جديده من
العربيه نبداها بهذه النشره بكره
ضد الحركه الثوري بينما ستقدم دائره
القانونيه بالاتحاد الاوروبيه مسوده
للاعضاء حول شرعيه هذه الخطوه في غضون
الاسابيع ثلاثه المقبله
افادت مصادر ايرانيه بانطلاق السفارات
الانذار في مدينه بناها الكرديه غرب ايران
امس ولم يتضح بعد سبب انطلاق السفارات
اتصل الرئيس الفرنسيه
لضبط النفس بعد احداث القدس الغربيه
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين بتجنب التصعيد
ابدا استعداده للمساهمه في استئناف الحوار
بين الجانبين كما عبر عن قلقه من انشطه
ايران التي وصفها بالموزعه للاستقرار في
المنطقه وفي الشعر النوويه دعم الى اعتماد
الحزم او الحزن لمواجهه ما وصفها
بالتطورات المغلقه الاخيره في ظل افتقار
طهران للشفافيه في برنامجها النووي
وفي شان الايرانيين اخر اكد نائب وزير
الخارجيه خارجيه اذربيجان ان بلده لا تثق
في ايران بشان ضماني امن موظفي سفارتها في
طهران وتم تعليقه عمل السفاره الدبلوماسيه
في طهران بشكل كامل مشيرا الى ان خمسه
موظفين بقوا في البعثه الدبلوماسيه
وسيتولون حراسه المبنى الامني والاداري
وممتلكات السفاره مؤكدا انهم لم يقوموا
باي انشطه دبلوماسيه
افادت مصادر عربيه بين طائرات يعتقد انها
طبيعه التحالف الدوليه قصفت رتلا من
الشاحنات بعد عبورها الاراضي العراقيه غرب
محافظه الانبار في مدينه القائم على شريط
الحدودي وسمع دوين تجارات على الشريط
الحدودي العراقيه السوريه مصادر عربيه
اكدت انها 25 شاحنه عبرت من العراق الى
سوريا من منفذ يسيطر عليه حزب الله
العراقي فيما افاد المرصد السوري بتدمير
الست شاحنات تبريد في البوكمال السوريه
جرى غاره جويه
الشاحنات تدمرت بشكل كامل هناك قتله همم
يعني على الاقل هناك خمسه قتله من سائقي
الشاحنات ومرافقين في هذا القصف الذي
افتدف الشاحنات هذه الشاحنات لا نعلم من
كان يقودها قلت لك بان قالوا بانها اصبح
صحيح يعني هو بشكل خطير لا تحمل في
الشاحنات يعلم بانها لم تكن طحين وكانت
تحمل الاسلحه تابعه للايرانيين تنقل الى
الاراضي السوريه هل كانت بطريقها الى
لبنان ايضا لا نعلم لان حتى لو كان لبنان
كانت الحموله فيجري تفريغها في منطقه
الميادين عاصمه ايران في شرف سوريا
اكد المستشار الالمانيه
لم تسمح بتحول الحرب في اوكرانيا الى صراع
بين روسيا وحلف شمال الاطلسي واضافها بعد
لقائه رئيس تشيلي في اطار جوله في امريكا
اللاتينيه ان برلين ساهمت في ضماني عدم
حدوث تصيد صراع ستكون له عواقب وخيمه على
العالم باسره والى حرب بين روسيا ودول
مؤكدا مواصله بلاده للعمل على منع حدوث
ذلك واوضح سلطه انه رئيس الامريكي جو
باردن يرفضاني ارسال قوه الى اوكرانيا
تجنبا لتصعيد الصراع
اعلن رئيس الاوكرانيه
ان بلاده تواجه وضعا صعبا للغايه في منطقه
دونيسك في ظل الهجمات الروسيه المستمره لا
سيما في بخموط وبولدر واضاف زلزال في
خطابه اليوميه ان روسيا تريد ان تطيل
الحرب وتنهق القوه الاخرىنيه
اسلحه جديده لاوكرانيا
لضمان ان ضغطنا لا يزال يفوق قدرات
الهجمات الروسيه ومن المهم للغايه الحفاظ
على زخم الدعم الدفاعين وشركائنا فالسرعه
امدادنا بالاسلحه هي احد العوامل الرئيسيه
في هذه الحرب
الرئيس الامريكي
على خرسون ادى الى مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص على
الاقل واصابه سته اخرين فيما قال حكموا
منطقه خاركيف ان صاروخا اصابا مبنى سكني
في مدينه خرتيب ثاني كبرى المدن
الاوكرانيه ما ادى الى مقتل شخص واصابه
اخرين واظهرت صور لرويترز من الموقع
النيران التي تلتهم جزءا من المبنى
السكنيه
[تصفيق]
يتفقوا عسكريون غربيون ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا في طريقها للتوسع والانتقال الى
حرب مدمره ويعزون السبب للبدء بوصول اسلحه
غربيه ثقيله الى اوكرانيا الدعم الغربي
نقل الاخيره من الدفاعي الى الهجوم نحو
عشرات الدبابات يتامل الغرب ان تغير وضع
القوات الاوكرانيه على الارض شكل الجذريا
لصالحها الا ان موسكو ترد بتوقعات معاكسه
مؤكده ان الدبابات الغربيه لن تغير
المعادله على الارض لا تقتصر الحزمه
الجديده من الاسلحه على دبابات اليوبارد
وابرز بل انتقلت المساعدات الى المستوى
اخر من الدعم
بالمدرعات من طراز برادل
ومضادات الالغام التواغلي في مناطق
السيطره الروس اسلحه هجوميه
بامتياز
ومقابله كل سلاح غربيا هجومي تضع روسيا
سلاحا رادعا ربما لا يقل شده عن نظيره
وكان الرد الروسي على قرار الاسلحه
الجديده
وبلا من الصواريخ على مدن اوكرانيه ووعدا
بادخال اسلحه اقوى الى ساحه الحرب
وبينما تامر القوات الاوكرانيه ان تشون
هجوما خلال الربيع منتهيه فرصه ان روسيا
تستجمع قواها وتجدد امداداتها من الذخيره
والسلاح يتوقع ان يتخذ الرئيس الروسي
بلادي مير بوتين خطوه للسباقيه قبل حزمه
المساعدات العسكريه ويشونه هجوما جديدا
على اوكرانيا في فبراير القادم بحسب ما
نشرته
ان ياتون الحرب ستكون في ذروتها ولا ربما
ستمتد حمامها لدول الجوار ايضا اذا عمر
العربيه
كشفت صحيفه الجارديان البريطانيه ان
المعركه الكبرى في اوكرانيا ستبدا في ربيع
القادم وتوقعت ان تكون اشد مراحل الحرب
دراوه منذ بدايه الحرب المزيد مع زميله
ليال المعركه الكبرى في اوكرانيا ستبدا
خلال الاشهر القليله المقبله والسؤال الذي
يطرح نفسه هنا من سيضرب اولا وايت سؤال
طرحته صحيفه الجاردن بريطانيا لنبدا بخط
المواجهه في الجنوب الاوكراني الذي يبلغ
طوله 1200 كيلو متر ومن المتوقع وفق خبراء
عسكريين تحدثوا للجاردن ان تندلع هناك اشد
مراحل الحرب دراوى منذ بدايه الحرب وفي
انتظار اطلاق شراره الحرب وشراره المعركه
القادمه روسيا تعمل على تقويه قوتها عبر
تحريك وتوجيه اقتصاد البلاد نحو الصناعه
الحربيه من اجل انتاج طبعا دبابات وصواريخ
جديده وفقا لهاؤلاء الخبراء بعدما مثلت
المرحله الاولى من العمليه العسكريه حرب
[__] كبيره للجانب الروسي همم طبعا للكريم
لين كلفته الاف الجنود بالاضافه الى
الخسائر التي لحقت بالترسانه الصاروخيه
التي استخدمت فيها واستخدمت بقصف البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه باوكرانيا اما الجانب
الاوكراني فيتحضر لاخذ زمام المبادره
والشروع بالهجوم اولا والسباق الهجمات
الروسيه ولكن غياب الاسلحه الثقيله
لاختراق المواقع الروسيه يتسبب لها بحاله
احباط الا اذا كان للدبابات الغربيه التي
استلمتها مؤخرا كلام اخر هناك ثلاث جبهات
يمكن ان تكون ساحه للمعارك الضاريه في
الربيع المقبل ويمكن ان يكون حسم اي واحده
منها ومنعرجا حاسما لهذه الحرب جبهه الشرق
وهنا نتحدث عن لهانسك ودنياسك التي كانت
مسرحا لاشد المعارك في الاشهر القليله
الماضيه وهي طبعا اكثر الاماكن احتماليه
لشنها جمال كبرى من كلا الجانبين في على
المقبل جبهه الجنوب في اتجاه جزيره القرم
طبعا وهي الجبهه الاهم بالنسبه للطرفين
الاوكراني والروسيه لانها طبعا ستقرر
نتيجه الحرب برممتها سواء شنت القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه الهجوم الاول في الشرق
ام لا وتبقى طبعا جبهه الشمال حيث تحشه
روسيا قواتها للتدريب بيلاروسيا ولكن يبقى
هذا الامر خدعه من قبل موسكو لابعاد
القوات الاوكرانيه عن الجنوب والشرق بحسب
الصحيفه
طلب الامير العامل الناتو ينسى السلطان
كوريا الجنوبيه خلال زيارته الى صول
بزياده الدعم العسكريه لاوكرانيا رحله
السلط مباشر اليابان وتهدف الى تعزيز
العلاقات مع حلفاء الولايات المتحده في
مواجهه الحرب في اوكرانيا والمنافسه
المتزايده مع الصين
ونبقى معكم في سياق هذه النشره ولدينا
في مقابله للعربيه بلانكين يدعو لوجود
حكومه واضحه وشرعيه تمثل الشعب الليبي
نوصلوا مع حضراتكم تقديم هذه النشره اتهم
عضو مجلس النواب عن مدينه الزاويه علي ابو
زريبه في تسجيل ان حصلت العربيه على نسخه
من اتهم اجهزه امنيه حكوميه في طرابلس
بمحاوله ابتزازه بسبب مواقفه داعمه
للاستقرار وانهاء تواجد حكومه البيبه
احنا اليوم نتكلم ببعض التفاصيل على
الجهاز
لمن الداخلي بما قام بين عمليات ابتزاز
حول بعض الشخصيات السياسيه وبعض الشخصيات
الاجتماعيه
السبب منع دخول سيد فتحي بشاره ومباشره
العمل من تقابل وهو
مرض الدول الخارجيه التي كان لها مصالح
حقيقيه ان تستمر ليبيا في الفوضى الموجوده
حاليا سواء كانت السياسيه او العسكريه
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه في مقابله مع
العربيه ان واشنطن تعيد اجراء الانتخابات
في ليبيا في هذه المرحله واكد ان ليبيا
تحتاج الى حكومه واضحه وشرعيه تمثل الشعب
الليبي مع الحفاظ على وحده ليبيا والتي لن
تتم الا بالانتخابات التي تعبر عن الشعب
في هذه المرحله حاجه التوجه الى
الانتخابات في ليبيا وان تكون هناك حكومه
واضحه تدعم طموحات الشعب الليبيه وهذا ما
تحدث عنه مبعوث الى ليبيا وعلى الحكومه ان
تكون شرعيه وتلبي تطلعات الشعب
اظهرت الارقام الاوليه في تونس ان نسبه
المشاركه في جوله الاعاده من الانتخابات
البرلمانيه التي جرت امس الاحد بلغت احد
عشر فاصل 3% حسب المتحدث باسمي هيئه
الانتخابات
توجه الى صناديق الاقتراع في الشوط الثاني
من الاستحقاق التشريعيه بنسبه مشاركه بلغت
11.3% الى حدود الساعه السادسه
جميع مراكز الاقتراع سجلنا تصويت
187,000 و 638 من الاخر اي بنسبه
الجمله للمسجلين طبعا
153,000 و 447 هذه النسبه قلت هي نسبه
دقيقه مع هامش
وفي سؤال للعربيه الحدث عن اسباب تراجع
نسب الاقبال على التصويت اكد المسؤولون عن
هيئه الانتخابات انهم قاموا بكل ما يلزم
لانجاح الانتخابات مع ضروره البحث في
الاسباب هذا التراجع اكيد عنده اسبابه
واسبابه اكيد متعدده سياتي الوقت ربما
للتقييم ويجب ان يكون التقييم علمي
وموضوعي
عمليه التصويت في مختلف الدوائر تمت بشكل
عادي اما من توجه الى مراكز الاقتراع
فقالوا انهم ينتظرون ان تعود ثقه ويتم
القطع مع المنظومه القديمه لابد من المضيء
الى الامام هذه فرصه التاريخيه لن تتكرر
بفرض ارادته والقطع مع المنظومات القديمه
اللي حاشتنا بها تسترجع الثقه وقت اللي
يقول له تونس بالفم على التونسي ان يبادر
على التونسي ان يقوم همم ما هو واجب عليك
لتتحسن الاوضاع
وينتظر ان تعلن النتائج الاوليه بدايه
الشهر القادم على ان تعلن نتائج النهائيه
في شهر مارس اصغر المقبل
وبعد حسن المصاري التشريعيه في انتظار
استكمال الطعون والاعلان عن النتائج
النهائيه تتوجه الانظار صوب تركيز
البرلمان الجديد بوصفه اخر محطه في المسار
الاصلاحيه والقطع مع المنظومه القديمه
وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس
الوطنيه
الى توحيد موقفها من اجل رحيل رئيس الصعيد
وتنظيم انتخابات مبكرا وذلك اثر تسجيل
المشاركه ضعيفه في دوره ثانيه للانتخابات
النيابيه وتوجه رئيس الجبهه احمد نجيب
الشابي في هذا الصدد للاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل وعماده المحامين ورابطه
حقوق الانسان وادعى الحركه السياسيه
والمدنيه للعمل لاحداث التغيير وتشكيل
قياده سياسيه جديده
في تركيا من المقرر ان يعلن قاده وحزاب
المعارضه الرئيسيه السته خلال مؤتمر
المواسع اليوم برنامج الانتخابيه ورؤيتهم
الكامله للحكم واداره البلاد في حال فوزهم
بالانتخابات وقالت مصادر في حزب الشعب
الجمهوري وحزب المستقبل المعارضين قالت
للعربيه ان وثيقه السياسات المشتركه تتضمن
2500 بند هي خطه عمل الحكومه ومؤسسه
الدوله بينما تتضمن خطط لانتقال الى
المرحله الانتقاليه قواعد اختيار مرشح
المعارضه والمرشحين الى الانتخابات
النيابيه واليات الانتقال الى النظام
البرلماني مع الخطط الزمنيه لهذه العمليه
المعارضون قالوا انهم يهدفون للعوده الى
النظام البرلماني المعدل ويرفضون النظام
الرئاسي الحالي الذي يعطي كل الصلاحيات
رئيس الجمهوريه كما اكد المعارضون دعم
احقيه الرئيس اردوغان بالترشح لولايه
الرئاسيه جديده على اعتبار انه حياته
الحاليه هي الرئاسيه وهي الثانيه والاخيره
استطعدت رئيسه الحكومه الفرنسيه اللي دابت
بورن التراجع عن خطه رفع سن التقاعد مع
استعداد النقابات لجوله احتجاجات واضرابات
جديده يوم غدا الثلاثاء وشددت رئيسه
الحكومه على ان رفع الحد الادنى لسن
التقاعد من 62 عاما الى 64 عاما والذي
اقترحه الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون من
ضمن حزمه من الاصلاحات غير قابله للنقاش
والتفاوض من جانب اخر وصفت اكبر ثماني
نقبات في فرنسا وفي توافق نادر بينها وصفت
الاصلاح بانه غير عادل وقالت انها تؤمن في
ان تتجاوز احتجاجات الثلاثاء القادم
لاحتجاجات التي نظمت في 19 من يناير وانت
تكون اكبر تعبئه
هذا وتوجه باريس تحديات حول اعاده نفوذها
في بلدان اخرى بمنطقه الساحل الافريقي في
الوقت الذي يرى مراقبون تناميا للنفوذ
الروسيه في البلدان ذاتها والتي كانت من
بينها مالي
على خطى مالي تسير بوركينا فاسو شيئا
فشيئا يتراجع النفوذ الفرنسي في منطقه
الساحل خروج فرنسي ودخول للنفود الروسي من
الابواب نفسها ولكن عمليه احلال وتبديل
النفوذ جاءت على مراحل وفقا للخبراء
نهايه مهمه فرنسا التي يبلغ قوامها نحو
400 جندي في بوركينا فاسو تاتي بعد 10
اشهر من طرد قواتها من مالي المجاوره
نهايه في مالي وبوركينا فاسو وبدايه في
النيجر المتخمه للبلدين
الوجود الروسي داخل الساحل وافريقيا لم
يتم بين ليله وضحاها يرى خبراء ان روسيا
قامت بحملات دعائيه للتاثير على السياسه
الافريقيه لصالح موسكو في المقابل تم حظر
الاذاعه الفرنسيه في بوركينا فاسو وفي
مالي هتف المئات امام السفاره الفرنسيه
رافعين الاعلام الروسيه
القياده العسكريه الجديده في كل من
بوركينا فاسو ومالي تريد حليفا جديدا نمت
العلاقات بين الكريملين والقاده السياسيين
في منطقه الساحل حتى اصبحت روسيا الشركه
المحتمل في الحرب ضد الارهاب وتحقيق ما
اخفقت في فرنسا
تعزيز الوجود الروسي في منطقه الساحل
الافريقي لا يخلو من الانتقادات الغربيه
في الواجهه يرى الغرب ان وجودها اسهم في
انهيار بطيء لقوات حفظ السلام التابعه
للامم المتحده والموجوده في مالي انسحاب
لقوات المانيه وبريطانيه ودينيماركيه
وسويديه انتقادات لم تحرك ساكنا امام رياح
التوجه الجديد من منطقه الساحل فبعد عقود
من السيطره الفرنسيه والتراجع الشعبيتها
تضع روسيا موتها لاقدامها بين شركائها في
افريقيا
على السمان العربيه
قال رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه بمجلس
النواب الامريكيه معك المقال انه يوافقوا
على بيان الجنرال في القوات الجويه
الذي اشار فيه الى ان واشنطن قد تكون في
حاله حرب مع بكين في عام 20 25 فيما عبر
مكان في برنامج فوكسي نيوز عن امله ان
يكون الجنرال مخطئا في توقعه المتعلق
بالحرب مع الصين معتبران ان اهتمام الصين
بغزو جزيره تايوان التي تعتبرها جزء من
اراضيها يعد محافظه واضحا الحرب واكد ما
قال على ان الامدادات العسكريه للولايات
المتحده غير كافيه في مواجهه الصراع
المحتمل مع الصين او اي دوله اخرى
كشفت صحيفه طولسترول في تقرير ان معهد
صينيا تابعا للحكومه تجاوز قيود الصادرات
الامريكيه على الرقائق الالكترونيه واشباه
الموصلات
حرب جديده قد تستعرض بين الولايات المتحده
والصين تستخدم فيها اصغر الاسلحه في
العالم الرقائق الالكترونيه واشباه
الموصلات التي باتت جزءا اساسيا في
تكنولوجيا السلاح الجديد
لابحاث الاسلحه النوويه تابعا للحكومه
الصينيه اشترى رقاقات كمبيوتر متطوره من
الولايات المتحده بشكل غير مباشر اكثر من
اثنتي عشر مره خلال سنتين ونصف السنه
العقده تكون في ان عمليه الشراء غير
المباشر تجاوزت قيود التصدير الامريكيه
المفروضه منذ عقوده والتي تهدف الى منع
استخدام اي من منتجات الولايات المتحده
لابحاث الاسلحه الذريه من قبل قوى خارجيه
وهو ما يفعله مع هذا الابحاث الذي اشترى
رقائق مكونات لانظمه الحوسبه المخصصه
للاستهلاك الشخصي من بائعين في الصين
المعهد الذي يعرف باسم الاكاديميه الصينيه
للفيزياء الهندسيه من اوائل المؤسسات
الصينيه التي ادرجتها واشنطن على القائمه
السوداء بسبب ابحاثها النوويه واستخدامها
لاشباه الموصلات الامريكيه في تلك الابحاث
لتحليل البيانات وانشاء الخوارزميات
مخاوف وعبرت عنها وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه
في نوفمبر الماضي قائله الى الصين تسرع
قدراتها النوويه
البنتاجون قدر ان الجيش الصيني سيخزن
حوالي 1000 و500 راس نووي بحلول 2035
بينما العدد الحالي هو 400
وتكون المشكله في السيطره على امتلاك تلك
الرقائق في انه يتم تصنيعها خارج الولايات
المتحده ما يصعب مهمه مراقبه الصادرات
ووجهتها النهائيه
وفي ختام هذه النشره نذكر بابرز العناوين
اوروبي لتصنيف الحركه الدوليه منظمه
ارهابيه ومكرون قلق من افتقار طهران
لشفافيه في برنامج النور
الى صراع بين موسكو ونيته وقصف الروسيه
على خرسون وخر كاف
والمعارضه التركيه تعلن برنامجها
الانتخابي اليومي لهزيمه اردوغان وتخطط
لاعاده النظام البرلمانيه بدلا من
الرئاسيه
نلتقي بعد قليل في خدمه الاخباريه جديده
من العربيه ابقوا معنا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]